hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game also from round seven
of the 2020 Tata Steel masters edition
it's a former World Chess Championship
challenger Fabiano Caruana versus Daniel
dubov and it's very interesting they
will be they played the same line Anand
played against Carlsen but if you
remember I said at some point cross and
took a 20 minute thing deciding where to
go with the night well do-over chose a
different approach so without further
ado let's check it out and I also showed
you the wrong standings after round 7 in
the previous video they weren't wrong it
was just before they published Bobby's
and DuBose results so we also have to
take that into consideration but ok
Bobby opens with E 4 and like I said
they go into the same Sicilian as Anand
versus Carlson Knight f3 knight c6 we
have the Rosalie MOBA shop to b5 sorry
about that
we have g6 same as Carlson played we
have castles Bishop g7 C 3 preparing d4
Knight f6 defending the pawn rook to e1
castles and now d4 lubob replies to the
same as Carlsen we have d5 and now II
five attacking the knight here and here
if you remember calls and took that 20
minute thing deciding whether to go an
idea thrown itv4 magnus went to Knights
to eat but here Du Bois goes Knight to
e4 and it's also very interesting
because Fabi of course was expecting
this Sicilian to show up in the world
chess championship so here fabi's
definitely digging into his world chess
champion championship preparation so
Bishop to e3 continuing development with
Queen to b6 now putting pressure on the
bishop but also on the b2 point if the
bishop moves
so first Bishop captures B captures and
queen c1
defending the pawn here and now rook to
b8 as the B file opened up now
threatening to pick up the pawn b3
defending and now Queen to a5
so what do you do here the threat is
rook captures on b3 but this has all
been played before so it's nothing new
d captures on c5 by Fabi allowing this
rook captures on b3 8 characters and now
Queen captures on a1 and now there is
one game in the world rapid championship
in 2019 Google D played it against the
rules
we're back overnight the default was
played and the GU curse was able to win
this game but here Fabi goes for B for
defending the c5 pawn also taking away
the a5 square from the White Queen and
now Knight to d4 will be very
interesting as you will have some
problems defending the c6 pawn so it is
as a move 15 that we have a completely
new game
so here Queen back to a4 again the Queen
back into the game also defending the c6
pawn right away Knights the d4 and this
is all calculated as yes you do give up
the e5 pawn but it's a it's a most
interesting pawn sacrifice it's been a
long time since I've seen such a such a
exquisite positional pawn sacrifice so
bushel captures on e5 is played and now
f3 kicking back the night and you don't
have any good square for the knight you
have to go to f6 and now your bishop is
kind of locked here on e5 and this is a
an elaborate plan to get rid of blacks
the bishops pears so Queen to a3 forcing
a Queen trade we have Queen captures and
Knight captures and now rook to e8 by
black and here comes the Bishop to g5 so
now you have some problems you cannot
allow f4 f4 you will not be able to move
the bishop if you move the bishop bishop
captures on f6 and your rook e8 will
hang so here there really is no good
movie you can't move the bishop as it's
under attack and you can't well even if
you could defend it you cannot really
allow f4 so here Bishop captures on d4
this is how Fabia gets rid of the bishop
pair C capture son d4 fixes this pawn
structure and just King g7 now this is
necessary so if Bishop captures you can
capture with the king and now b5 a nice
a nice breakthrough on the Queen side we
have Bishop to d7 and now Fabi has to
decide between captures and b6 b6 also
seems very interesting for example
captures captures and rook b8
rugby 1 defending the pass pawn and it's
already a very strong passed pawn
however it's hard hard to see how you
would promote it all the way you could
well let's say better before you try to
kick away the rook rook b7 and it's of
course playable but Bobby decides to go
for B captures on c6
which is very interesting I to me
pushing the pawn seems a more
straightforward more natural but okay
our Fabi decides to do it this way point
is after beat Bishop captures on c6 now
Fabi has a firm grasp on the e5 square
firm grip and you he doesn't want the
black to ever play e5 to ruin this setup
and he's now gonna go after the a7 phone
so this is how Fabi decides to do it the
show back to d2 and we have a six now
trying to create a barrier with Bishop
to b5 with night the c2 Bishop to b5 and
now rook to a one preparing nice to be
four to go after the a6 pawn we have
Knight to d7 hoping to execute a five
but Knights the b4 and here a five could
be could be very dangerous if played for
example a five year you can go c6 and
Knight b6 and now D captures on e5 and
you cannot recapture because of gosh up
to c3 pinning the rook as the king is
still in g7 so you would first have to
go d4 then comes c7 and you don't have
time to to pick up the e5 pawn you have
to block it rook to c8 and now Knight
captures on h6
so it's although the engine gives this
as playable for black I don't know it's
hard to say if anyone would would go for
this will black but okay he sex by dubov
he can always push me five so let's just
strengthen that d5 pawn as it was also
under attack with the night and now
comes Bishop to f4 now if we capture
here then rook to e8 so you don't want
to capture it too soon so first Bishop
to f4 again grabbing the hold of the e5
square and also preventing the roof from
reaching be 8 so rook to e8 adding a
defender here and now rooked a5 and not
allowing the pawn to be pushed
we have Knights to be 8 and now comes g4
first you want to play g5 take care of
both of these pawns and then you want to
start bringing your King into the game
so King f8 both dubov and 5e start
bringing their king is inter game King
e8 we have G 5 now Knight to d7 and now
comes Bishop to c7
just a nut
the king to go anywhere closer we have
f6 and the now h4 if you capture I'm
still gonna cover all of these squares
so it's not a problem
rook to e7 attacking the bishop and now
Bishop to d6 the bishop is very strong
here we have broke back to a 8 and now
comes King III with King to f7 and now
f4 by Fabi King g7 now comes King d2 we
have h 5 and just King to C 3 so Google
has to wait and see what what Bobby will
do and still it's very interesting new
move it still has six points fabula five
five but it is that it was that's why I
thought it was a very very exquisite
pawn sacrifice because black is as of
that moment
Black is just helpless to see what white
will do King back to f7 now we have 9th
to d3 and now Bishop back to c6 we have
King Tubby for and now rook the a7 you
cannot go Ruby check so Luke a 7 and now
rook to a3 and here fabi's plan is to
bring the knight 2 c1 2 b 3 maybe to a5
and and see what happens and here I
thought why not
rugby 7 check and indeed rook to b7
check seems like the way to go because
if you go up the board with King here
then you can just give up the pawn and
you will never you know get your King
away from all the checks so it would be
even very dangerous for Y to do this so
after Luke the b7 check it's most likely
that you will have to go back and then
just look back to a7 so I think that
this plan is no good
probably night before is coming next
then there should be five and still how
are you how are you breaking through
here but dubov says okay I'm not
interested in this obviously it's not a
good plan so he just keeps waiting King
g7 night the c1 Duggal repeats King to
f7 and now tonight the b3 we disrupted
b5 and now Knight to a5 so dubov allowed
Fabi to continue with his plan
rook the a8 and now Fabi finally makes a
go for it c6 pushing back the knight
Knight b6 and now c7 and now it's of
course very dangerous you already have a
passed pawn on c7 it's a defended passed
pawn so should be should be good if you
can push it all the way of course we
have F 5 by 2 above
closing the position here and now rook
to e3 somehow if if the knight can reach
a let's say tonight be seventh the c5 go
after the e6 pawn might be difficult for
for dubov to defend it
so first rook the c8 now the knight can
move with Knights to b7 continuing with
this plan
Knight to c4 now and here comes rooked
back to e1 here you could go for the
planner like Knight the d8 check King
moves and now rook captures on e6 check
King d7 and rook captures on g6 yes you
grab a lot of pawns and this seems to be
excellent for white but then you require
a lot of calculation for example Knight
capture some b6 but then you have to see
a ruby g7 check King Teti 8 and now g6
so it's a really elaborate piece
sacrifice and it's not decide easy to go
for something like this if there should
be seven you just eliminated captures
captures g7 and there's no stopping the
pawn but it's a it's a hard to figure
all this out in in you know in all of
this mess so far beam just moves the
rook rook e1 and the now comes push up
to d7 here you you cannot to just go a
night capsule because the knight
captures with check and you lose the
rook
so after rook e1 we have Bishop to d7
guarding the e6 pawn one more time but
now King c5 Bobby gains more activity
with the King King g8 and the now comes
Bishop to e5 so freeing up the d6 square
for a moment that you don't have access
to it as the knight nicely covers it
from c4 but there's there are still
moves to be made King f8 and now rook
back to a1 so going after the a6 pawn
and now again there's the problem you
cannot just remove the defender of the
c7 pawn because of King d6 now attacking
the knight and the bishop and after
anything Knight checks you will capture
here and is just over Knight b6 check
you're gonna go King to d6
and after another check now King to c6
and next Knight to d6 is coming and it's
just a winning game for white so Bishop
back the b5 guarding the pawn but now
Bishop d6 check again you cannot capture
to the shop as Knight captures just wins
King g8 and now Knight to a5
if Abby's able to get rid of this night
from c4 night back to be - and now
Bishop to e5 making room for the king as
long as the night isn't c4 the King can
never reach the b6 square so King to b7
but now finally King to b6 making making
some real progress here and now nice the
CC for check by do both otherwise you
can just wait and there is nothing for
you to do we have Knight captures and
here D Capra's and c4 du Bois gets a
passed pawn of his own King to c5 and
now comes Luke t8 we have rook to d1
preparing to pull the pawn but now
Bishop to a for attacking the rook rook
back bay back to a-1 Bishop to b5 back
and now rook to a2 we have came back to
see it now the king will be preventing
the pump to be pushed and now King d6
and here
dubov is just a running out of squares
to use King b7 we have Bishop to f6 we
have King back to c8 better back to d8
King back to b7 doogal can only wait and
repeat moves King to e5 and now the
passed pawn is nicely protected here and
the thread is king f6 followed by
characters captures captures and it's
just game over
so rook f8 preventing king of six but
now rotate three first giving black the
move so black worsens the position of
asking even further it's a very
instructive idea ruk ruk a3 so King back
to c8 even our you know even worse
position for the king and only now King
captures an e6 or if rook defends then
you just go after these guys here so
rook e8 check King f7 and now
Du Bois finally gains activity with the
rook but now it's it's a capture fest so
King characters and g6 rook captures on
f4 and now comes King captures on h5
freeing up room for the g5 passport to
be pushed rook captures on d4 and now
g6 we have worked the d6 hoping for
hoping for g7 and bishop teh check but
even that doesn't help black
so King to g5 first and now rook the d3
just hoping for for this trade but now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning move for Fabi
while I give
a couple of seconds now for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
there is more than one winning more for
Fabia but there is the quickest way
which is the one Fabi choice and that is
g7 so here there's nothing to be done if
you capture the pawn if you capture the
rook then it's not pushing in the right
away because then you run into Ruby g3
check and the pawn is picked up but King
h6 in fact and now after rook g3 just
block the book with Bishop to Bishop to
g5 and the queening is next so we have
c3 freeing up the c-4 square for the
bishop so you can guard this and of
course you still cannot Queen because of
Luke g3 picks up the Queen
so just keen capture Sun f5 rook g3
Bishop to g5 very very natural rush of
the c4 guarding the queening square but
now rook captures on a6
we have c2 by do both but it's not a
problem rook to c6 and now Bishop guards
the c1 square also the rook will be
guarding it we rush up the b3 and here
Fabi just played h5 and it was in this
position that Daniel Du Bois resigned
the game and Fabi joins
well not the leaders but sort of the
leaders who are trying to catch up to
all areas of Arusha so here there's
nothing to do h6 h7 queen is coming and
there's nothing you can do to prevent
this so yeah and here are the actual
standings there you can see fob is also
on four and a half points with Wesley so
and Jordan went forest so that's what we
forgot to mention yesterday even though
I took it from the from the original
website but they still haven't updated
it and otherwise of course still leading
with five out of seven so in very
impressive stuff but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it very very
impressive play by Fabi like I said
surely he dug up into that World Chess
Championship preparation as this was
just a masterclass really really
impressive stuff so yeah I would like to
thank Robert Fischer for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
the Women's World Chess Championship so
thank you all I will see you soon and
heaven
excellent rest of your Sunday